This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1987, Touchstone Pictures released a buddy comedy called Outrageous Fortune. Outrageous Fortune wasn't a flop, but it was overshadowed by some of the year's bigger movies. Robocop, Predator, Three Men and a Baby. That's producer Jacob Reed. The main reason I know about Outrageous Fortune is a bizarre rumor I heard in film school.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1987年，试金石影业发行了一部名为《恶女帮》（Outrageous Fortune）的搭档喜剧片。《恶女帮》并非票房惨败，但被当年一些更重磅的电影掩盖了光芒。比如《机械战警》、《铁血战士》和《三个奶爸一个娃》。那是制片人雅各布·里德。我之所以知道《恶女帮》，主要是因为我在电影学院时听过一个离奇的传闻。
A rumor about how the stars were credited. The film starred Shelley Long and Bette Midler. Or maybe it was Bette Midler and Shelley Long. It depends who you ask. Supposedly the studio somehow promised both actresses they'd be the top-billed star of the film. And it got pretty contentious. Here's Bette Midler doing a Q&A the following year. You and Shelly Long were great together in Outrageous Fortune.
一个关于主演如何署名的传闻。这部电影由雪莉·朗和贝特·米德勒主演。或者也可能是贝特·米德勒和雪莉·朗。这取决于你问的是谁。据说制片厂不知何故向两位女演员都承诺了她们将是该片的头牌明星。这导致了相当大的争议。这是贝特·米德勒第二年参加问答环节时的情景。你和雪莉·朗在《恶女帮》里合作得非常棒。
I was wondering if you guys were going to work together again. I don't think so. No? No, I don't think so. Did you enjoy working with her? I, I, it was pretty rough. It was rough. The rumor about Outrageous Fortune is they could never decide who got top billing and ended up releasing two different cuts. One where Bette Midler's name comes first and one where the first name is Shelley Long.
我想知道你们以后还会合作吗？我想不会了。不吗？不，我想不会。你喜欢和她合作吗？我，我，那段经历相当艰难。确实很艰难。关于《恶女帮》的传闻是，他们始终无法决定谁该排在第一位，最终发行了两个不同的版本。一个版本是贝特·米德勒的名字在前，另一个版本是雪莉·朗的名字在前。
To satisfy the two stars, the studio allegedly created two versions of the film and released them on opposite sides of the country. The East Coast got Shelly Long as the top build star and on the West Coast, Bette Midler was the top build star. And releasing two cuts of a film at the same time, that's almost never done. I know because I'm a director and a graphic designer.
为了满足两位明星，制片厂据称制作了两个版本的电影，并在全国各地分别发行。东海岸看到的版本中雪莉·朗是头牌明星，而在西海岸，贝特·米德勒是头牌明星。同时发行一部电影的两个版本，这几乎是闻所未闻的。我知道这一点，因为我本人就是一名导演和平面设计师。
So I've done a little work in title design for my own films and I've designed title sequences for other people. They can get messy, but it always gets figured out by the final cut. Deciding who gets top billing in a movie can be a delicate balancing act. Because when you're watching the opening credits to a movie, it's not just a list of names. What you're actually seeing is intense negotiations by Hollywood stars and their agents playing out in text form.
所以我为自己的电影做过一些片头设计，也为其他人设计过片头序列。这可能会变得很混乱，但最终剪辑时总能解决。决定谁在电影中获得头牌署名可能是一种微妙的平衡艺术。因为当你观看电影的片头字幕时，它不仅仅是一串名字。你实际上看到的是好莱坞明星及其经纪人以文字形式进行的激烈博弈。
Title designers have to create something that's entertaining to watch, while also presenting the names of all the creative people in a very particular order. It's like a game of Tetris to make sure everyone gets their due. Hollywood agents, producers, and studios decide who gets top billing in a movie. But it's title designers who figure out how to represent that information visually.
片头设计师必须创作出既具观赏性，又能以非常特定的顺序呈现所有主创人员名字的作品。这就像一场俄罗斯方块游戏，以确保每个人都得到应有的位置。好莱坞经纪人、制片人和制片厂决定谁在电影中获得头牌署名。但正是片头设计师想出了如何以视觉方式呈现这些信息。
You know, what I do is I look at the history and the breadth of this art form, because it truly has been an art form that has existed since the dawn of cinema. That's Lola Landekich. She runs one of my favorite websites. I'm the editor-in-chief of Art of the Title, an online resource and archive for title sequence design in film, TV, and beyond. Art of the Title is a visual encyclopedia of title sequences that counts directors like Ava DuVernay, David Fincher, and Guillermo del Toro among its fans.
你知道，我所做的是审视这种艺术形式的历史和广度，因为它确实是一种自电影诞生以来就存在的艺术形式。那是萝拉·兰德基奇。她经营着我最喜欢的网站之一。我是《Art of the Title》的主编，这是一个关于电影、电视及其他领域片头序列设计的在线资源和档案库。《Art of the Title》是一部片头序列的视觉百科全书，其粉丝包括艾娃·杜威内、大卫·芬奇和吉尔莫·德尔·托罗等导演。
One thing I love about title sequences is how they use design to artfully and efficiently set up story elements for the movie or TV show. You especially see this in TV because, you know, each episode is meant to begin with the same sequence, so you watch it over and over, so it's sort of meant to get you into the world, get you right into the tone. Title sequences can be metaphorical. Like in Mad Men, an enigmatic figure tries to maintain control as he spirals from the height of the 1960s Madison Avenue advertising industry as it falls apart in his wake.
关于片头序列，我喜欢的一点是它们如何利用设计来艺术且高效地为电影或电视节目铺陈故事元素。你在电视节目中尤其能看到这一点，因为你知道，每一集都以相同的序列开始，所以你会反复观看，它旨在让你进入那个世界，让你直接进入那种基调。片头序列可以是隐喻性的。就像在《广告狂人》中，一个神秘人物试图保持控制，同时从20世纪60年代麦迪逊大道广告业的巅峰跌落，身后是一片狼藉。
Title sequences can also be a detailed guide to the show you're about to watch. -♪ Like each season of Game of Thrones, where an intricate map helps viewers keep track of the complicated locations, characters, and plot points. And, of course, title sequences can also be literal. Like the opening sequence from the min-series Little Fires Everywhere.
片头序列也可以是你即将观看的节目的详细指南。-♪ 就像《权力的游戏》的每一季，复杂的地图帮助观众追踪错综复杂的地点、人物和情节要点。当然，片头序列也可以是直白的。就像迷你剧《星星之火》的开场序列。
Big idea. We were going to start a lot of little fires. We were going to burn their props, their key props. Karen Fong is a title designer who led the team that created the opening sequence for the mini-series Little Fires Everywhere. It's an evocative sequence where multiple items burn to a crisp in slow motion. We did the last day of the shoot when they didn't need the props anymore, obviously. We took their key props of key items that were very important to the plot and the story,
宏大的构想。我们要点燃许多星星之火。我们要烧掉他们的道具，他们的关键道具。凯伦·方是一位片头设计师，她带领团队创作了迷你剧《星星之火》的开场序列。这是一个令人回味的序列，多个物品在慢动作中烧成灰烬。显然，我们是在拍摄的最后一天做的，当时他们不再需要这些道具了。我们拿走了对情节和故事非常重要的关键道具，
and we lit them on fire. To Karen, the job of a title sequence is setting tone, and maybe more importantly, setting audience expectations. You know, as a title designer, I believe my primary goal is to set the audience up for what they're about to see. You know, to set a tone, set an emotion, and it's almost like creating a portal into another world. Right, it's a kind of a ritualized way
然后把它们点燃了。对凯伦来说，片头序列的工作是设定基调，或许更重要的是，设定观众的期望。你知道，作为一名片头设计师，我认为我的首要目标是让观众为他们即将看到的内容做好准备。你知道，设定一种基调，设定一种情绪，这几乎就像创造了一个通往另一个世界的入口。没错，这是一种仪式化的方式
of entering a story space. But while setting a tone is important, title sequences primarily exist to give us information. Here's Lola Landekich. Title design is primarily a vessel for information. That's why it's a design rather than necessarily what we would consider a kind of standalone fine art. It's a project created to serve a larger work.
进入故事空间。但虽然设定基调很重要，片头序列主要还是为了提供信息。这是萝拉·兰德基奇。片头设计主要是一个信息的载体。这就是为什么它是一种设计，而不是我们通常认为的那种独立的纯艺术。它是一个为更大作品服务的项目。
A title sequence can be creative, it can be clever, but the primary goal is to give the list of credits. Early in her career, Karen learned this lesson working for legendary comedy director Harold Ramis. Karen was trying to get fancy with the typography and the title sequence for one of his movies, and Ramis didn't like that. And just Harold Ramis just looked at me once during a screening and he said, Karen, people need to see their names. So that was just like a lesson to us, like, oh, right. You know, we can do all these things for the mood and we do, but at a fundamental level, right, we are showing, we're showing the cast and crew days.
片头序列可以很有创意，可以很巧妙，但首要目标是提供演职员表。在职业生涯早期，凯伦在为传奇喜剧导演哈罗德·雷米斯工作时学到了这一课。凯伦试图在他的一部电影的片头序列中把排版做得花哨一些，但雷米斯不喜欢那样。哈罗德·雷米斯在放映时看着我说，凯伦，人们需要看到他们的名字。所以这对我们来说就像是一个教训，哦，对。你知道，我们可以为了氛围做所有这些事情，我们也确实做了，但在根本层面上，我们是在展示演职员。
All title projects include guidelines, but with Hollywood egos involved, title designers need to be very careful how names are laid out, since there are always a series of negotiated placements that have to be respected. I would describe film credits as potentially the most hotly negotiated term in a performer's contract. That's Daniel McDill, an entertainment attorney who focuses on film production.
所有的片头项目都包含指导方针，但涉及到好莱坞的自尊心时，片头设计师需要非常小心名字的排列方式，因为总有一系列必须遵守的协商后的位置。我会把电影署名描述为表演者合同中可能最激烈协商的条款。这是丹尼尔·麦克迪尔，一位专注于电影制作的娱乐律师。
An agent or a talent attorney and production counsel will negotiate three-second type-8 font credit for weeks trying to get the performer the best position possible. I've designed title sequences for features, and let me tell you, it is wild how many requirements there are. One actor's contract might say same size and type as other leads, but then the lead actor's contract says no less than the size of the director's title, and the DGA, which is the director's guild, requires the director's title be no less than 50% of the film's title, and it is a mess.
经纪人或人才律师和制作顾问会为了三秒钟、8号字体的署名协商数周，试图为表演者争取尽可能好的位置。我为长片设计过片头序列，我告诉你，要求之多简直疯狂。一位演员的合同可能写着与其它主角相同的大小和字体，但随后主角的合同又写着不小于导演头衔的大小，而美国导演工会（DGA）要求导演的头衔不得小于电影片名的50%，这简直是一团糟。
Everyone wants to be no less than 50% of the film's title, and it is a mess. Everyone wants to be first. Top billing is the best credit, usually before title. So if you're on your own card, that means you're by yourself before the title and you're number one. You have most of the time the best position possible, we call that top-billed star. Like Bette Midler and Shelly Long in Outrageous Fortune.
每个人都希望不小于电影片名的50%，这简直是一团糟。每个人都想排在第一位。头牌署名是最好的署名，通常在片名之前。所以如果你有自己的独立卡位，这意味着你在片名之前独自出现，你是第一位。你大多数时候拥有尽可能好的位置，我们称之为头牌明星。就像《恶女帮》里的贝特·米德勒和雪莉·朗。
Or Shelly Long and Bette Midler in Outrageous Fortune. Beyond top billing, the hierarchy is usually dictated by the size of the role and the name recognition of the actor, with all the major characters in the main title sequence and everyone else in the end credit scroll. One exception, Daniel says, is that within a whole bunch of names, any name that stands out can be valuable. The first, the last, and then any modifiers like introducing or featuring. Sometimes you'll see at the last credit is
或者《恶女帮》里的雪莉·朗和贝特·米德勒。除了头牌署名，等级通常由角色大小和演员的知名度决定，所有主要角色在主片头序列中，其它所有人都在片尾滚动字幕中。丹尼尔说，一个例外是，在一堆名字中，任何突出的名字都可能很有价值。第一个、最后一个，以及任何修饰语，如“介绍”或“特邀”。有时你会看到最后的署名是
and Robert De Niro or with Dame Judi Dench. Like these are very prolific established actors, but they're not top-billed, and you're probably wondering why and when they'd be first. A lot of the times we reserve the and credit or the with credit for a prominent, established, esteemed performer who's not a star of the film.
“以及罗伯特·德尼罗”或“特别出演朱迪·丹奇女爵”。这些是非常多产、资深的演员，但他们不是头牌明星，你可能想知道为什么以及他们何时会排在第一位。很多时候，我们为那些不是电影明星但地位显赫、资深、受人尊敬的表演者保留“以及”或“特别出演”的署名。
Top billing can go along with better career prospects, more money, and a big reputational boost. Actors want the credit they deserve because they haven't always gotten it. In the early days of the Hollywood studio system, actors were signed to years-long contracts as repertory players for a studio. Those studios could decide what roles they could play
头牌署名可以带来更好的职业前景、更多的金钱和巨大的声誉提升。演员们想要他们应得的署名，因为他们并不总是能得到。在好莱坞制片厂制度的早期，演员们被签下长达数年的合同，作为制片厂的驻场演员。这些制片厂可以决定他们能扮演什么角色，
and had total control over an actor's career and image. But over time, actors won more autonomy. If you look at the egos behind these positions that they're taking, it's kind of reclaiming yourself, your profession, and your craft. And if fighting over a credit position helps you do that, it's legitimate in the sense that when you look at a $400 million movie, you want to get as much of that as you can. A big part of a title designer's job, whether they like it or not, is being the last stop on the legal train.
并对演员的职业生涯和形象拥有完全的控制权。但随着时间的推移，演员们赢得了更多的自主权。如果你看看他们争取这些位置背后的自尊心，这其实是在重申你自己、你的职业和你的技艺。如果为了争取署名位置而斗争有助于做到这一点，那么从某种意义上说，这是合法的，因为当你面对一部4亿美元的电影时，你想要尽可能多地获得你应得的。片头设计师工作的一大部分，无论他们是否喜欢，都是成为法律流程的最后一站。
They're the ones who turn specific legal negotiations into something that holds an audience's attention. Here's Karen Fong again. When we get a title sequence project, there is a legal document or there's a credit list that has all the specs of the credits. This document is essentially a blueprint that lists all the specs for credit sequence,
他们是将具体的法律谈判转化为吸引观众注意力的东西的人。这是凯伦·方。当我们接到一个片头序列项目时，会有一份法律文件或一份包含所有署名规格的名单。这份文件本质上是一份蓝图，列出了署名序列的所有规格，
including order, sizing requirements, and anything else the studio, production companies, agents, and guilds have agreed on. My Guild, the Directors Guild of America, requires that a director must be listed closest to the title of a project. So when you see a main title, the director's name is always last. But if you're seeing an end title, movie ends, directed by comes up. So you have this whole list of requirements, which Karen says can be several pages in a Word doc with two columns.
包括顺序、尺寸要求以及制片厂、制作公司、经纪人和工会商定的任何其它内容。我的工会，美国导演工会，要求导演必须被列在项目名称最靠近的位置。所以当你看到主片头时，导演的名字总是最后一个。但如果你看到的是片尾字幕，会出现“导演”字样。所以你有这一整套要求，凯伦说这可能是一个两栏的Word文档，长达几页。
The actual title or name on the left and then any corresponding legal requirements on the right. It is incredibly thorough. Lola and I watched the title sequence of one of my favorite movies, The Fugitive, and it has a particularly interesting design challenge. What I want out of each and every one of you is a hard target search of every gas station, residence, warehouse, farmhouse, henhouse, which tells you that they both have top billing. Both of their names are very clearly made to be the exact size of the title.
左边是实际的头衔或名字，右边是任何相应的法律要求。这极其详尽。萝拉和我观看了我最喜欢的电影之一《亡命天涯》的片头序列，它有一个特别有趣的视觉设计挑战。“我需要你们每个人都对每一个加油站、住宅、仓库、农舍、鸡舍进行地毯式搜索”，这告诉你他们两人都有头牌署名。他们的名字都被非常清晰地制作成与片名完全相同的大小。
This is something that you see a lot, especially in the 80s and 90s with like lead action stars, Bruce Willis, Schwarzenegger, Jackie Chan. They would often have stipulations in their contracts saying their name has to appear 100% the size of the title of the film. Which is challenging since not all names are created equal. The Fugitive is 12 characters, Harrison Ford is 13, and Tommy Lee Jones is 15.
这是你经常看到的情况，特别是在80年代和90年代，像布鲁斯·威利斯、施瓦辛格、成龙这样的动作巨星。他们的合同中通常会有条款，规定他们的名字必须以电影片名100%的大小出现。这很有挑战性，因为并非所有名字都是平等的。《亡命天涯》（The Fugitive）有12个字符，哈里森·福特（Harrison Ford）有13个，汤米·李·琼斯（Tommy Lee Jones）有15个。
To make them all the same size, the title designers did an interesting thing where the letters turn to reveal the first and last names of each actor and the letters subtly stretch out. And despite the different character count, it's pretty seamless. There's a flashlight going through the text,
为了使它们大小相同，片头设计师做了一件有趣的事情，字母转动以显示每位演员的名字和姓氏，字母会微妙地拉伸。尽管字符数不同，但它相当无缝。有一束手电筒光穿过文字，
kind of beginning that theme of investigation and darkness and trying to seek the truth. So everything's on point. The toughest title design challenge is when two stars both want top billing. You know, the Bette Midler-Shelleylong situation. Because there's only one name that can actually be first on a list. For decades, this was a central conundrum of title design. No one could settle on the best way to do it because no matter what was tried,
开启了调查、黑暗和寻求真相的主题。所以一切都很到位。最艰难的片头设计挑战是当两位明星都想要头牌署名时。你知道，贝特·米德勒和雪莉·朗的情况。因为名单上实际上只能有一个名字排在第一位。几十年来，这是片头设计的核心难题。没有人能确定最好的解决方法，因为无论尝试什么，
one star's name would inevitably just look better than the other. In the end, a solution was found on a beloved 1970s network comedy. What we call in the industry normally is a Laverne and Shirley. I learned that in law school and I had to look up what Laverne and Shirley was. So I didn't know the show, but I knew about the telesequence before I knew about the show. Three, four, five, six, seven, eight, chlamile, chlamas, Austin Bebven, corporate. We're gonna do it.
一位明星的名字不可避免地看起来会比另一位更好。最终，在一个深受喜爱的70年代电视喜剧中找到了解决方案。我们在行业内通常称之为“拉文和雪莉”式布局。我在法学院学到了这一点，我不得不去查什么是《拉文和雪莉》。所以我不知道这部剧，但在知道这部剧之前我就知道这个片头序列了。三、四、五、六、七、八，我们要去做了。
Give us any chance we'll take. Laverne and Shirley was a sitcom that ran for eight seasons on ABC from 1976 to 1983, starring Penny Marshall and Cindy Williams. Hearing the music, you might picture the two of them skipping through the streets of Milwaukee to their job at a beer bottling factory. This is shot at the brewery in Van Nuys. I think originally in the outline they were just walking down the street and then they go, again, they were, you know, oh, no, I don't want to do that.
给我们任何机会我们都会抓住。 《拉文和雪莉》是一部情景喜剧，从1976年到1983年在ABC播出了八季，由佩妮·马歇尔和辛迪·威廉姆斯主演。听到音乐，你可能会想象她们两个在密尔沃基的街道上跳跃着去啤酒装瓶厂上班。这是在范奈斯的酿酒厂拍摄的。我想最初在大纲里她们只是走在街上，然后她们说，不，我不想那样做。
That's kind of boring. So they did their little skip, and that became the thing. I got to watch the Laverne Shirley title sequence with producer Nick Abdo, and he worked on the show from 1976 to 78. One of his first jobs was as an associate producer on Happy Days. There was an episode of Happy Days where they were dating.
那太无聊了。所以她们做了她们的小跳步，那成了标志性的动作。我有幸和制片人尼克·阿布多一起观看了《拉文和雪莉》的片头序列，他从1976年到1978年在该剧工作。他最早的工作之一是《欢乐时光》的助理制片人。《欢乐时光》里有一集她们在约会。
And Richie ended up dating Shirley, and Fonzie was dating Laverne. And they scored really big. I mean, the audience loved them. The network says, well, why can't we do a show about them? The producers took all the Laverne and Shirley parts from the Happy Days episode, edited that together, and then filled in some other scenes to make a pilot.
里奇最终和雪莉约会，方兹和拉文约会。他们的反响非常好。我的意思是，观众很喜欢她们。电视网说，好吧，为什么我们不能为她们做一部剧呢？制片人把《欢乐时光》那一集中所有关于拉文和雪莉的部分剪辑在一起，然后填补了一些其它场景来制作试播集。
The network loved the pilot, but there was a practical issue getting the show off the ground. Both actresses wanted top billing. Sound familiar? According to Nick, this had never come up before in TV. No, no, I think this was the first one. With up-and-coming actors based on characters that organically developed on another show, there wasn't a clear way to establish the hierarchy of the credits.
电视网很喜欢这个试播集，但在启动该剧时有一个实际问题。两位女演员都想要头牌署名。听起来耳熟吗？据尼克说，这在电视界以前从未出现过。不，不，我想这是第一次。对于基于在另一部剧中自然发展出的角色的新晋演员来说，没有明确的方法来建立署名等级。
One idea was to switch the names every week. At some point, there's going to be a mistake. They're going to put the wrong one and then there's going to be a big lawsuit. How can we solve this now? Let's troubleshoot it before it's trouble. According to Nick, one of his colleagues had a flash of inspiration for how to fix this. And I don't know who it was that came up with it. It might have been Eddie Milka
一个想法是每周交换名字。在某个时候，肯定会出错。他们会放错名字，然后就会有一场大官司。我们现在怎么解决这个问题？让我们在麻烦发生前解决它。据尼克说，他的一位同事对如何解决这个问题有了灵感。我不知道是谁想出来的。可能是埃迪·米尔卡
said, I'm not sure. Said, well, why don't we put the left bottom and the top right? This was a major turning point in title design. You have one name top right, the other name bottom left. Imagine the hands of a clock at two and seven. Top right, bottom left. When it comes to design, there are a couple of givens. In English, we read text top to bottom,
我不确定。他说，好吧，为什么我们不把一个放在左下角，一个放在右上角？这是片头设计的一个重大转折点。你有一个名字在右上角，另一个名字在左下角。想象一下时钟指针在两点和七点的位置。右上，左下。说到设计，有几个既定事实。在英语中，我们从上到下阅读文本，
left to right, and big to small. This kind of title card split means two names can be given roughly equal prominence. Here's Karen Fong. Karen Fong, Author, The New York Times Because they're splitting the difference, right? One person's lower, but the first read on the left and one person is higher and is on the right side, which is the second position when you're going left to right.
从左到右，从大到小。这种片头卡位分割意味着两个名字可以获得大致相等的突出地位。这是凯伦·方。因为她们平分了差异，对吧？一个人位置较低，但在左侧先被阅读，另一个人位置较高，在右侧，这是从左到右阅读时的第二个位置。
So it's evening it out, right? Because if somebody, you know, was top and left, that would definitely be the first thing you'd read. And the first position in the hierarchy of titles is the superior position. So, as far as I could tell, Laverne and Shirley wasn't the first project to do this. You could actually see it in the 1974 film, The Towering Inferno. Bottom left is Steve McQueen, top right is Paul Newman. But in Hollywood, everyone associates this kind of title with Laverne and Shirley.
所以这平衡了它，对吧？因为如果有人在顶部和左侧，那绝对是你首先会读到的东西。而在署名等级中，第一个位置是优越的位置。所以，据我所知，《拉文和雪莉》并不是第一个这样做的项目。你实际上可以在1974年的电影《火烧摩天楼》中看到它。左下角是史蒂夫·麦奎因，右上角是保罗·纽曼。但在好莱坞，每个人都把这种署名方式与《拉文和雪莉》联系在一起。
These days, it's pretty common to see Laverne and Shirley titles. The entertainment industry has been going through enormous changes over the last decade. And while everyone we asked had different reasons about why stars are sharing cards more often, today the Laverne and Shirley layout is everywhere, especially on television. In The Last of Us for Bella Ramsay and Pedro Pascal and a lot of things like that that very clearly have two major stars. I think even May December has a similar layout for Julianne Moore and Natalie Portman. There's Damian Lewis and Paul Giamatti in Billions,
如今，看到“拉文和雪莉”式的署名相当普遍。娱乐业在过去十年中经历了巨大的变化。虽然我们询问的每个人对于明星为何更频繁地共享卡位都有不同的理由，但今天“拉文和雪莉”式的布局无处不在，尤其是在电视上。在《最后生还者》中，贝拉·拉姆齐和佩德罗·帕斯卡，以及很多类似有两位大明星的作品。我想甚至《五月十二月》对于朱丽安·摩尔和娜塔莉·波特曼也有类似的布局。还有《亿万》里的达米安·路易斯和保罗·吉亚玛提，
Reese Witherspoon and Jennifer Aniston in The Morning Show, Matthew McConaughey and Woody Harrelson in True Detective, Martin Freeman and Benedict Cumberbatch in Sherlock. Oh, yeah, and Kerry Washington and Reese Witherspoon in Little Fires Everywhere. ["FIRE"] Previously on Little Fires Everywhere, we were talking about the little fires. They're everywhere.
《早间新闻》里的瑞茜·威瑟斯彭和詹妮弗·安妮斯顿，《真探》里的马修·麦康纳和伍迪·哈里森，《神探夏洛克》里的马丁·弗瑞曼和本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇。哦，对了，还有《星星之火》里的凯莉·华盛顿和瑞茜·威瑟斯彭。 ["火"] 在上一集《星星之火》中，我们谈到了星星之火。它们无处不在。
They're even burning up a Laverne and Shirley title card with Reese Witherspoon and Kerry Washington on it. That was pretty obvious, I think, from the front, from the very first credit list. They were always double billed or double equal billing. To get them equal, one person's lower to the left and one person's upper to the right. Giving two people top billing seems like it shouldn't be possible. And for a long time, it wasn't. Until Laverne and Shirley codified a simple solution to a Hollywood problem.
它们甚至烧毁了一张带有瑞茜·威瑟斯彭和凯莉·华盛顿的“拉文和雪莉”式署名卡。我想从第一份署名名单开始，这就很明显了。她们总是双重署名或双重平等署名。为了让她们平等，一个人在左下方，一个人在右上方。给两个人头牌署名似乎是不可能的。很长一段时间里，确实如此。直到《拉文和雪莉》为好莱坞的问题编纂了一个简单的解决方案。
But as I reported this story, something kept eating at me. The Laverne and Shirley compromise was invented in the 1970s. Why wouldn't they use it for outrageous fortune ten years later? Remember the movie where Shelley Long and Bette Midler fought over top billing? Was the rumor really true about two different releases? I had to get to the bottom of what is maybe the greatest mystery in all of title design. I got in touch with reps for both Midler and Long, but they declined to comment. had to get to the bottom of what is maybe the greatest mystery in all of title design. I got in touch with reps for both Midler and Long, but they declined to comment.
但当我报道这个故事时，有些事情一直困扰着我。 《拉文和雪莉》的妥协方案是在20世纪70年代发明的。为什么十年后他们不在《恶女帮》中使用它呢？还记得雪莉·朗和贝特·米德勒争夺头牌署名的那部电影吗？关于两个不同版本的传闻是真的吗？我必须查清这可能是片头设计中最伟大的谜团。我联系了米德勒和朗的代表，但他们拒绝置评。
I watched the movie on streaming. But if there were multiple versions of the film, it's likely only one was digitized. So I went to the pantheon of arcane cinema knowledge. I'm talking, of course, about a video store. My name is Matt Booth. I'm the owner of Videodrome, the last video store in Atlanta, Georgia. And my name is Millie DiCerico. I was a former employee of Videodrome. Millie didn't say this, but she was also a programmer at TCM. For those who don't know, that's Turner Classic Movies.
我在流媒体上看了这部电影。但如果电影有多个版本，很可能只有一个被数字化了。所以我去了神秘电影知识的殿堂。我指的当然是一家录像带租赁店。我叫马特·布斯。我是亚特兰大Videodrome的老板，这是佐治亚州最后一家录像带店。我叫米莉·迪切里科。我曾是Videodrome的员工。米莉没说，但她也曾是TCM的节目策划。对于那些不知道的人，那是特纳经典电影频道。
Yeah. OK, so just to recap here, the rumor about outrageous fortune isn't just that both actresses were promised top billing. The bigger story here is the completely bizarre way the studio honored that deal. They came to this sort of compromise where there was a divided the United States down the middle and created two separate releases. Bette Midler would take the West Coast and be the top billing,
是的。好的，回顾一下，关于《恶女帮》的传闻不仅仅是两位女演员都被承诺了头牌署名。这里更大的故事是制片厂履行该协议的极其离奇的方式。他们达成了一种妥协，将美国一分为二，制作了两个独立的发行版本。贝特·米德勒占据西海岸并获得头牌署名，
and Shelly Long would be the top billing on the East Coast. Let's use the Mississippi River as the dividing line between who was gonna be on top for this release. I mean, that is wild to me. Depending on which side of Mississippi you saw the film, supposedly the newspaper ads, the posters, the movie marquee, and even the title sequence of Outrageous Fortune was different.
而雪莉·朗在东海岸获得头牌署名。让我们以密西西比河为界，划分谁在这个版本中排在前面。我的意思是，这对我来说太疯狂了。根据你在密西西比河哪一侧观看这部电影，据说报纸广告、海报、电影院招牌，甚至《恶女帮》的片头序列都是不同的。
The cover is very, it's very iconic. It's kind of the two of them holding on to the edge of a cliff. There's a helicopter below, their them holding on to the edge of a cliff. There's a helicopter below. Their nails are on point from hanging on to this cliff. The cover is actually reversed. The art's reversed on the different releases. So they're switched in their places. Yeah.
封面非常具有标志性。有点像她们两个抓在悬崖边缘。下面有一架直升机，她们抓在悬崖边缘。她们的指甲因为抓着悬崖而非常显眼。封面实际上是反过来的。不同发行版本的艺术设计是反过来的。所以她们的位置互换了。是的。
Depending on who was billed on the two separate releases. It's the kind of solution that only worked in the pre-internet age. You know, like a two-timing Lothario telling two women they were his number one and hoping they just never found out about each other. Which by the way, happens to be the plot of Outrageous Fortune. To find out if there was any validity to this rumor, we asked Matt and Millie to find and watch multiple copies of the film in the middle of the video store.
取决于谁在两个独立的发行版本中被署名。这是一种只有在前互联网时代才行得通的解决方案。你知道，就像一个脚踏两只船的浪子告诉两个女人她们是他的唯一，并希望她们永远不会发现对方。顺便说一句，这恰好是《恶女帮》的剧情。为了查明这个传闻是否有任何真实性，我们请马特和米莉在录像带店里找到并观看该电影的多个拷贝。
All right. So we're here to run an experiment on both versions of Outrageous Fortune. Two laser discs. One of the laser discs has Shelley Long's name and Shelley Long's body on the cover art on the left. And then the other one, which is flipped. Then we have two VHS covers. So we've got one working laser display, we have two VHS players, and we have two monitors that we're going to sort of pop each movie in at the same time. And we're going to check the credit sequence to see if it matches the cover boxes. As Matt and Millie fired up their Laserdiscs, a technology that was introduced when a
好的。所以我们在这里对《恶女帮》的两个版本进行实验。两张激光影碟。其中一张激光影碟的封面艺术左侧是雪莉·朗的名字和雪莉·朗的身体。然后另一张是反过来的。然后我们有两个VHS封面。所以我们有一个工作的激光影碟播放器，我们有两个VHS播放器，我们有两个显示器，我们打算同时播放每部电影。我们要检查署名序列，看看它是否与封面盒匹配。当马特和米莉启动他们的激光影碟时，这是一种在
movie ticket cost $2.75, something occurred to me. It's a PSA. Oh, man, I have trailers on the beginning of mine. And she's got trailers. She has a Good Morning Vietnam trailer is playing on mine. Even with the existence of a practical design solution in the Laverne and Shirley Compromise, the outrageous fortune story is kind of perfect. Mine's Bette Midler.
电影票价为2.75美元时引入的技术，我突然想到了一件事。这是一个公益广告。天哪，我的开头有预告片。她也有预告片。我的正在播放《早安越南》的预告片。即使有了“拉文和雪莉”妥协方案这种实用的设计解决方案，《恶女帮》的故事也堪称完美。我的是贝特·米德勒。
Oh, Shelley Long. This one has Shelley Long at the top. Oh my God, what in the world? Oh my God, what in the world? Because in the end, no design solution can totally account for Hollywood egos. Shelly Long is first. And this one had... ...Beth Midler on the top.
哦，雪莉·朗。这个在顶部有雪莉·朗。天哪，这到底是怎么回事？天哪，这到底是怎么回事？因为最终，没有任何设计方案能完全应对好莱坞的自尊心。雪莉·朗排在第一位。而这个有……贝特·米德勒在顶部。
More with Jacob Reed and some of our favorite opening title sequences after this. So we're back with Jacob Reed. Well thank you so much for doing that story with us. We talked a lot about the technical, legal aspects of title design, but I know you want to talk about some of the more artistic part of title design. Yes. I am a huge title design geek, and getting to talk to someone like Karen, who Karen Fong who works at Imaginary Forces, I could have talked to her forever. I mean, they've worked on Counterpart, which is one of my favorite shows ever, Spider-Man No Way Home. Her
稍后将有更多关于雅各布·里德和我们最喜欢的一些开场片头序列的内容。我们回到雅各布·里德。非常感谢你和我们一起做这个故事。我们谈了很多关于片头设计的技术和法律方面，但我知道你想谈谈片头设计中更艺术的部分。是的。我是一个巨大的片头设计极客，能和像凯伦·方这样在Imaginary Forces工作的人交谈，我可以和她聊上一整天。我的意思是，他们参与了《相对宇宙》，这是我最喜欢的剧集之一，《蜘蛛侠：英雄无归》。她的
team also did Stranger Things and South Park. I mean, Mad Men. They've done it all. And she has just so many good stories. Okay, like what? Okay, so did you ever watch the show Boardwalk Empire? No. I've been told it's great, but I missed that one. It's a great show. and it has this iconic title sequence where Steve Buscemi is kind of just looking out at the Atlantic Ocean and then a,
团队还制作了《怪奇物语》和《南方公园》。我的意思是，《广告狂人》。他们什么都做过。而且她有太多好故事了。比如什么？好吧，你看过《大西洋帝国》这部剧吗？没有。有人告诉我它很棒，但我错过了那部。这是一部很棒的剧。它有一个标志性的片头序列，史蒂夫·布西密只是看着大西洋，然后，
just a bunch of bottles wash up on the shore. Oh, that might be the one thing I have seen of Boardwalk Empire. That's all you gotta know. There's some story, but that's mostly what it is for however many seasons. Well, it's this iconic title sequence. What's so funny is in talking to Karen,
一堆瓶子被冲上岸。哦，那可能是我看过的《大西洋帝国》的唯一片段。你只需要知道这些。有一些故事，但无论多少季，这基本上就是它的内容。好吧，这是一个标志性的片头序列。有趣的是，在与凯伦交谈时，
I learned that was not her pitch at all. She had this whole other idea that had come from seeing the set for the first time. He would go to Brooklyn and there'd be these shipping containers and then lo and behold, you go around the secret passage, the shipping containers to the outside world, was the set and it was this full-on boardwalk. Like, he would go inside the candy store and
我了解到那根本不是她的提案。她有另一个完全不同的想法，源于第一次看到片场。他会去布鲁克林，那里会有这些集装箱，然后你绕过集装箱的秘密通道，外面就是片场，那是一个完整的木板路。就像，他会走进糖果店，
there's a taffy machine that works and everything was completely dressed so you could shoot from inside to outside. And so the original ideas all had to do with showing off, I mean, this amazing place that all of the researchers and production designers and costumers had made. So, that was Karen's original idea. But the show's creator, Terry Winter, really wanted to focus on introducing Buscemi's character because he's kind of like the center of the show. And at first, they couldn't do that because, I don't know, it was like a scheduling thing or something.
里面有一台能工作的太妃糖机，一切都布置得非常完美，所以你可以从里面拍到外面。所以最初的想法都与展示这个由所有研究人员、制作设计师和服装设计师制作的惊人地方有关。所以，那是凯伦最初的想法。但该剧的创作者特里·温特真的想专注于介绍布西密的角色，因为他就像是剧集的中心。起初，他们做不到，因为，我不知道，这就像是一个时间安排的问题之类的。
But then he became available. And I think they actually had started prepping the shoot for this entire other opening, and then they pivoted to just focus on Steve Buscemi. Suddenly it was all about him and his point of view, and that central idea being that the world was ever changing, but he was always going to be in the center of it. This is also something that speaks to being a tile designer.
但后来他有空了。我想他们实际上已经开始为另一个开场准备拍摄了，然后他们转向只关注史蒂夫·布西密。突然间，一切都围绕着他和他的视角，核心思想是世界在不断变化，但他将永远处于中心位置。这也是作为片头设计师的体现。
It's like, what do we do? And this is something, when I'm working with the team, we're always pondering, like, what do we do to make this show ownable? Like, if you create a tile sequence and it can go on another show, then it's not specific enough. What makes Boardwalk Empire different? And one thing that didn't make a difference
就像，我们该怎么做？这是我和团队工作时一直在思考的问题，比如，我们怎么做才能让这部剧具有独特性？如果你创作了一个片头序列，而它可以用于另一部剧，那么它就不够具体。是什么让《大西洋帝国》与众不同？有一件事没有造成区别
is that it was a story that took place on the Atlantic city, on the sea, which made it such a fertile place for all the rum running. And, you know, this is during Prohibition, and so the fortune of the city and of our main character was tied very much to smuggling liquor via the ocean. And so he looks out, and the bigger idea was he looks out and sees hundreds of bottles of whiskey floating. And that was really fun and a lesson for me just to be like, it's not our job to show what's in the show. You know, our job isn't to duplicate, that we're supposed to compliment it.
那就是这是一个发生在大西洋城、在海上的故事，这使它成为所有私酒贩运的肥沃土壤。而且，你知道，这是在禁酒令期间，所以城市和我们主角的命运与通过海洋走私酒类紧密相连。所以他向外看，更大的想法是他向外看，看到了数百瓶漂浮的威士忌。这真的很有趣，也是我的一课，让我明白，展示剧中有什么不是我们的工作。你知道，我们的工作不是复制，我们应该补充它。
We're supposed to lead into it. It's not a title, isn't a trailer. Karen also talked about some of her first experiences watching title sequences, being the interstitials on Sesame Street. And she had this cool full circle moment when they parodied Boardwalk Empire as Bird Walk Empire. That was one of the highlights of my career
我们应该引导它。片头不是预告片。凯伦还谈到了她第一次观看片头序列的经历，即《芝麻街》的插曲。当他们恶搞《大西洋帝国》为《鸟类帝国》时，她有一个很酷的圆满时刻。那是我的职业生涯亮点之一
is to see shot for shot, like instead of the liquor bottles in the water, there were saltines floating in the sea, and it was big birds feet instead of Steve Buscemi's on the sand. All right, quackers, follow me. We're going to take a walk on the bird walk. Whatever you say, Nucky Ducky, you're the boss. All right, you heard a movie.
看到逐个镜头的模仿，比如水里不是酒瓶，而是漂浮的苏打饼干，沙滩上是巨大的鸟脚而不是史蒂夫·布西密的脚。好吧，嘎嘎们，跟着我。我们要去走鸟类大道了。随你便，纳基鸭子，你是老板。好吧，你听到了电影。
Water, water, water. Quack, quack, quack ["Water, Water, Water," by The Bachelorette plays.] That's hilarious. Burnwell, Campfire. I love it. It's great. Roman, do you have any favorite TV or movie title sequences? I mean, the first one that really knocked me flat was the title sequence to Seven, because it was doing so much work. It was really trying to solve this problem of introducing the serial killer.
水，水，水。嘎，嘎，嘎。 ["Water, Water, Water," by The Bachelorette 播放。] 这太搞笑了。《大西洋帝国》。我喜欢它。太棒了。罗曼，你有什么最喜欢的电视或电影片头序列吗？我的意思是，第一个真正让我震撼的是《七宗罪》的片头序列，因为它做了很多工作。它真的试图解决介绍连环杀手的问题。
You don't end up encountering him in the movie for an hour or so into it. Do you have a favorite of your own? I don't know if it's a favorite, but I've been rewatching Dexter a lot recently. And I think it's a great title sequence. It's all of it. It's really good.
你在电影中直到一个小时左右才遇到他。你有自己最喜欢的吗？我不知道这算不算最喜欢，但我最近一直在重看《嗜血法医》。我认为这是一个很棒的片头序列。它的一切。真的很好。
Yeah. So it's basically him making breakfast in the morning, but everything, these mundane, cracking an egg, pouring Tabasco onto toast, pulling a shirt over his head, flossing with the string of the floss tied up in his hands like he's about to choke someone. It takes all of these mundane things and gives them the serial killer treatment, and it just puts you in exactly the right mindset for the show.
是的。所以基本上是他早上做早餐，但所有这些平凡的事情，敲鸡蛋，往吐司上倒塔巴斯科辣酱，把衬衫套在头上，用缠在手上的牙线剔牙，就像他要勒死某人一样。它把所有这些平凡的事情都用连环杀手的方式处理，它让你进入了完全正确的观看心态。
It's brilliant. I totally love that one. Dead on. Well, this is awesome. It's fun talking about title sequences. I can see why people like the art of the title folks just have devoted their lives to these. Oh, yeah. I mean, we should plug that. I don't know if we're allowed to plug stuff, but we should plug that website.
太精彩了。我完全喜欢那个。非常准确。好吧，这太棒了。谈论片头序列很有趣。我明白为什么像《Art of the Title》的人们会把一生都奉献给这些东西。哦，是的。我的意思是，我们应该推广它。我不知道我们是否被允许推广东西，但我们应该推广那个网站。
It's the art of the title is one of my favorite websites ever. And it's if you're a graphic designer, a filmmaker, really anyone for inspiration, even if you're just like a film fan, it's really cool. That's awesome. Well, thank you so much, Jacob. I really had fun. Yeah, thank you, Roman.
它是《Art of the Title》，是我最喜欢的网站之一。如果你是平面设计师、电影制作人，真的任何人想要灵感，即使你只是一个电影迷，它也非常酷。太棒了。好吧，非常感谢你，雅各布。我真的很开心。是的，谢谢你，罗曼。
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Jacob Reed, edited by Chris Berube, fact checking by Graham Haysha, mix and sound design by Haseek Ben Ahmad Fareed, music by Swan Royale, our intern is Nikita Apte.
谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。《99% Invisible》本周由雅各布·里德制作，克里斯·贝鲁贝编辑，格雷厄姆·海沙核实事实，哈西克·本·艾哈迈德·法里德混音和声音设计，斯旺·罗亚尔配乐，我们的实习生是尼基塔·阿普特。
Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is the senior editor. The rest of the team includes Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Martin Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Don, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Nina Potuck, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. Special thanks this week to Grace Callis, Quincy Serresmith, Maya Croft, and Yang Yi. And a very special thanks to Claire Reynolds and to Matt Booth and the team at Videodrome in Atlanta,
凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔是高级编辑。团队其它成员包括杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、马丁·冈萨雷斯、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·雷、拉什玛·唐、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳、尼娜·波图克、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格和我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99% Invisible》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。本周特别感谢格蕾丝·卡利斯、昆西·塞雷史密斯、玛雅·克罗夫特和杨毅。还要特别感谢克莱尔·雷诺兹，以及亚特兰大Videodrome的马特·布斯和他的团队，
who tracked down multiple copies of Outrageous Fortune for our ridiculous experiment. If you're in the Atlanta area, absolutely you must go check them out. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California, home of the Oakland Roots Soccer Club, of which I'm a proud community owner. Other teams may come and go, but the Roots are Oakland first, always. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our brand new Discord server. There are over 4,500 people talking about Power Broker,
他们为我们荒谬的实验找到了《恶女帮》的多个拷贝。如果你在亚特兰大地区，一定要去看看他们。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区，潘多拉大厦以北六个街区，这里是奥克兰根足球俱乐部的所在地，我是该俱乐部的骄傲社区所有者。其它球队可能会来来去去，但根队永远是奥克兰的，永远如此。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，以及我们全新的Discord服务器。有超过4500人在讨论《权力掮客》，
talking about different episodes, talking about architecture in general. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
讨论不同的剧集，讨论一般的建筑。那里有一个链接，以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目，网址是99PI.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。